[Music]  when Stefani sings on the voice and  crushes it despite having an ear injury  [Music]  the 47 year old singer took the stage  Tuesday night alongside members of her  team and performed a flawless rendition  of Coldplay's Fix you even though gwen  ruptured her eardrum last week she  clearly didn't let it hold her back  when harmonized with her contestants and  wore in her ears like a champ throughout  the cover  [Music]  et spoke with Gwen's boy friend and  fellow voice coach Blake Shelton on  Monday or he gave a health update on his  ladylove she's getting better you know I  think something like that's just slow  I mean you pop your blow your eardrum  out I mean that's luck I don't even know  how that happens bout my high heels  either but she says she can hear now  [Music]  you